- Let me jog, I've been very lucky.
Something's got to be done.
- [Narrator] From the beginning
of former New York City Mayor
Michael Bloomberg's presidential campaign,
he bet on Super Tuesday,
seeing it as an opportunity
to enter the race
and scoop up a substantial
number of delegates.
- I'm in it to win it, and.
(crowd cheering)
- [Narrator] That didn't pay off.
Bloomberg ended his big for president
after winning only one nominating
contest in America Samoa.
- I entered the race for
president to defeat Donald Trump,
and today, I am leaving the
race for the same reason,
to defeat Donald Trump, because staying in
would make it more difficult
to achieve that goal.
- [Narrator] Tuesday's results
set up what looks to be more
like a two-person race
between former Vice President Joe Biden
and Senator Bernie Sanders,
but if you were looking
at your Facebook feed
ahead of Super Tuesday, it
probably didn't feel that way.
- [Woman] We have a choice to make.
- [Narrator] Bloomberg
spent at least $620 million
on building his campaign
and spreading his message
before dropping out.
About 75 million of that went to digital
where his social media strategy
was both unique and controversial.
At the center of those
efforts was Hawkfish,
a digital tech firm Bloomberg owns.
It was set up not just for him,
but to help Democrats generally.
- So Mike Bloomberg created
Hawkfish in spring of 2019,
and a lot of Bloomberg's
advisors really believed
that Trump won the 2016 election
because of their very
strong digital effort.
- [Narrator] So the firm's primary focus
was on digital advertising
on Facebook and Google.
Bloomberg ran ads on issues
such as climate change
and gun safety reform,
though most were focused on
attacking President Trump,
and that's something that could outlast
Bloomberg's bid for president.
Hawkfish also experimented
with new ways of reaching younger voters.
There was this meme or
Bloomberg's face on a meatball
and this one that the Bloomberg campaign
paid a popular Instagram account to post.
Separately, there was this doctored video
where Bloomberg asks--
- I'm the only one here I think
that's ever started a
business, is that fair?
- [Narrator] And the other
candidates appear to fall silent.
- So a bunch of Democratic
strategists and others
said that that video was misinformation.
The Bloomberg campaign said
it was tongue-in-cheek.
- [Narrator] More controversial, however,
was the Bloomberg campaign's use
of what it calls deputy digital
organizers in California.
The Wall Street Journal reported
that the campaign hired
hundreds of workers
to post regularly on their
personal social media accounts
in support of Bloomberg
and then send text messages
to their friends about him.
- While it's totally common
for different political
campaigns to ask their supporters
to spread the message by word of mouth,
it's quite unusual to
pay thousands of dollars
to get that support.
Then it gets into this murky
area of what the rules are,
so do you have to disclose if you're paid
for writing a post?
Yes, generally, you have to,
and the Federal Trade Commission
says you have to for businesses,
but the Federal Election Commission
which oversees campaign finance law
does not yet have a
specific rule on that front.
- [Narrator] A lot of tech
platforms like Facebook,
which owns Instagram, Google, and Twitter
have tried to set their own
rules for political content,
but their policies differ
on when and exactly what
a user has to disclose.
- We are in this ultra-digital
social media-infused climate,
and a lot of the rules have
not caught up to the content.
- [Narrator] Now the question is,
will Bloomberg keep
spending against Trump?
When ending his bid, he endorsed Biden.
Hawkfish is expected to keep
working on behalf of Democrats.
- Hawkfish has done work before
that doesn't involve Mike Bloomberg.
In the 2018 midterms, it worked
on state legislative races
in states like Kentucky and Virginia,
so we think it's possible
that they could do
that type of work again,
and sources have said
that they will stay open
throughout the general election.